こんにちは！ドク...ターーーはじめだ
君達は
お菓子食べるか？
有機物の1種でお菓子という物がある
人々はお菓子を娯楽として
生きているわけでもない。
その中でも棒状のねスティックのお菓子がとても人気がある
君達も食べたことがあると思う
その中でも一番有名なのがこちら
ボ、ポッキーだ
こういう棒状のお菓子がこの世界には沢山出回っているのだが
君達、非常に考えが甘い。
今の地球上何が起きるかわからない
ひょっとしたら、家が壊れて
その時持っている物が
ポッキーだけだったりすることがあるかもしれない
持ち物が棒状のお菓子だけだった時
助かることができるのか
否
その確率は非常に低い
例えばなんだがもし今ここで地割れが起きるとしましょう
私がこの隙間に落ちてしまった
もう手をこのなんか
指もこうやって床に引っかからない
こういう時にこうやってポッキーを掴んで
このままこうやって...あ、ちょっと待て
床が無理なんでここを掴むしかないわけですよ
こうやってなんとか力を入れて持ち上がって帰ってこれれば一番いいんだけども
この時のこのお菓子の強度が私はとても気になる
今のケースにおいて
持ち物は棒状のお菓子のみ
最大の危機の時に備えてこの棒状のお菓子何を持ってればいいか
今回は棒状のお菓子を色々準備してみた
皆それぞれ強度が違うので
落ちそうになった時に引っ掛けてフックの代わりとなるこの部分の棒状のお菓子は
どれが一番強いのか
棒状のお菓子の強度ナンバー1を今回は測っていきたいと思う
ではいこう！
この2つの台を使って実験をします
2本使います
こういう感じで
こういう感じで台の上に2本置いて
この上に重りを乗せます
それでこの2本の棒状のお菓子で耐えれるかどうかを測っていきます
最終的に一番重い物を乗せられていた
棒状のお菓子が勝ち
という
実験になっております
この実験ある意味ではポッキー達のウェイトリフティング大会
どの棒状のお菓子が強いのでしょうか
はい
2017年度
強度選手権大会
棒状-お菓子の部-が始まりました
実況は私、矢田が務めさせていただきます
よろしくお願いします
最初のプレイヤーはこちら
ポッキー、日本代表でございます
ファーストステージはガムテープということで
この重さに耐えられるかがポイント
今、乗りました
さあどう出る
ファーストステージ
おおーー
（クリア！）
（素晴らしいです）
（まずは日本代表クリアしました）
（次の試合が大切ですね）
（次の選手はこちら）
ポッキー極細（聯合王國）
（この重量級の試合をいかに乗り越なしていくかがポイントとなっております）
（今、選手が入場してきました）
（場所取りが大事でございます）
（しっかりと足を揃えて着地する）
（いざ）
（さあどう出るか）
（クリア！）
（素晴らしいです）
（ギリギリなんとか耐えれましたね）
（さあ続いての選手はこちら）
（プリッツでございます（韓國））
（えー引退がかかった試合となっております）
今年最後の挑戦
（さあ場所取りしっかりして）
（おおっこれはリーチが足りないからローリングステップですね）
（さあ耐えられるか）
クリアです
（素晴らしい、ローリングステップでのクリアとなりこれは得点が追加されますね）
（次の選手はこちら）
（ポッキーアーモンドクラッシュ）
（体にアーモンドを纏ってる選手でございます）
あ、1人死んじゃった
（どうしたんでしょうか、チーム名が1人負傷しましたね）
（負傷したチームメイトの分も頑張れるか）
（ポッキークラッシュ）
（さあ運命の瞬間です）
クリアです
（クリアです、なんとか優勝への第1歩を踏み出せました）
（次の選手はこちら）
（トッポ（委內瑞拉）です）
（今までの選手とは作りが違っておりまして）
（中にチョコが入っていると。）
（果たしてこの試合どう出るか）
（さあ計測中です）
（素晴らしい）
クリアです
（意外と余裕を持ったクリアでしたね）
（続いての選手はこちら）
（今大会唯一の女性参加者　ポッキー苺（俄羅斯）です）
（ハート型になっておりますが）
（これが果たしてどう出るか）
（耐えられるか）
（今、測定開始です）
クリアです
（クリア）
（ぎりぎりですね）
（おや？どうされたのでしょうか）
プリッツはローストと被ってるので失格ですね
（ここでプリッツローストが失格！）
（さあ波乱の一回戦ですが二回戦の出場選手はこちらの5名となっております）
（選りすぐりの名門高校出身の選手ばかり）
（この後どうする試合展開になるのか）
（第2ステージはお～いお茶でござ...あれ？）
（いや！お～いはじめさんです！）
（さあ第2ステージ最初の選手は）
（ポッキー）
（500mlですね）
（500グラム程の重りがあります、さあ耐えられるのかポッキー）
（今、挑戦の時をーーーおーーっとここで失敗）
（ここで日本ポッキー失格です）
（でも味は美味しいです）
（続いての挑戦者はこちら）
（プリッツ（韓國）ですね）
（リーチの短さがちょっと弱点ですがどう出るか）
（おーーーっとここで失格）
（プリッツも耐えられなかったか第2ステージ）
（でも美味しい）
（続いてはこちら）
（ポッキーアーモンドクラッシュ）
（チクチクのアーモンドがどうでるかですねこの試合は。）
ﾋﾞﾝﾋﾞﾝﾋﾞﾝﾋﾞﾝﾋﾞﾝﾋﾞﾝﾋﾞﾝ  ﾁｸｯ  ｱｰｰｲｸｯ
（500g）
（耐えられるか）
（運命の瞬間です）
（これは¿¿）
（素晴らしい、初の第2ステージクリア）
（この勢いで勝ちたい、トッポ（委內瑞拉）選手の挑戦です
（トッポは中がチョコレートなので時間が経てば経つほどスタミナ切れが弱点になってきます）
（さあ500gのお～いお茶）
（耐えられるか）
（これは！！）
（クリアーーー素晴らしい）
（さあこの勢いに乗って勝っていきたい）
（今大会唯一の女性選手　ポッキー苺（俄羅斯））
（500gのお～いお茶耐えられるかどうか）
（今、あーーっとこの顔です）
（さあいよいよ決勝戦）
（上がってきた選手はこちら）
（ポッキーアーモンドクラッシュとトッポでございます）
（さあこれで一番固い、一番強度の固い選手が決まる）
（決勝戦は野菜ジュース方式を利用させていただきます）
（1本あたり200gの重さがあり）
（徐々にジュースを増やしていくスライド方式を採用させていただいております）
（さあ最初の選手はこちら）
（ポッキーアーモンドチョコ）
（まずは200g）
（乗った、クリア）
（ここからどんどん”野菜一日これ一本”が積み重なっていく）
（400gクリア）
（ここが山場です、600g）
（さあ耐えられるか）
（おーーとここで骨折）
（いやーーーー残念な結果ですねー）
（さあこれでトッポ（委內瑞拉）が勝てば
この大会の優勝者はトッポ）
（中までチョコたっぷり）
（結構時間が経っておりますので中のチョコが溶けてきている）
（その点スタミナは持つのかどうか心配です）
（試験官がむせています）
（さあ200gは乗った、ここから600までいけるか）
（400g乗ったがトッポかなりそれている）
（グニャっと曲がっているが耐えられるか）
（観客からの応援コールが）
（拍手が巻き起こっている）
（いけるか）
（600g乗った！）
（クリアーーー）
トッポ優勝ーーー
（おめでとうございます）